welcome to this video playing goodnight
mr. Tom yeah sometimes it's tricky to to
to eat those names out so Queens gambit
this is amazingly popular right to check
but all adopt the lines that the top
players aren't going from you not that
this is a particularly bad thing to do
when I mean the the top players have
their reasons for playing a particular
line and quite often they are good right
but sometimes it feels a little bit like
yeah just yeah just like following
fashion without really thinking about
considerations like this is really the
right opening for me and deaf people
sometimes just blindly follow fashion
and it doesn't doesn't help at the end
okay I'm not accusing this guy or
anything just that it's kind of funny
how often you get this recently okay um
let's see him yeah the night to c5 is
the typical way of playing this and I
wasn't really sure look at AC monologue
fc1 maybe I took the the wrong night
there by the way that's possible okay
I'm going back for 94 95
yeah so I don't really mind this trade I
know the light squared Bishop is
something that it's not particularly
great for black but in general traits er
not bad for white at least them it's no
particular it's no particular reason to
avoid it don't need to make any
unnatural moves to just keep those
bishops on Wow ok I didn't expect that
one giving me the c5 square just like
that it ok with the light squared Bishop
traded that is not such a huge issue ok
p prevented this 97 my ideas doubling on
the C file then the Queen moving the
Queen away and then 93-95 this is the
the way to do it I think one issue is
that he really doesn't have any counter
play now okay not to be 6 by Kobe three
and then what exactly if I've a4 might
be might be an IDM yeah but I can play a
for myself a5 I can go a form
I can play for now i wonder if that is
an idea or not tricky decision
if i play
I quite tricky I think this is a good
decision but I'm not totally sure going
for a 5-1 problem was with this pawns on
a3 and b3 when i move the Queen and to
move the night a three is always hanging
so I try to push this pawn up Bishop c5
Luke c5 he cannot win on a for this porn
because Luke c6 is hitting first and if
he takes on a forward the pawn I can
check with the night which is just
excellent for white g six is basically
gone zone now and the idea is now to go
a five Quincy 393 and then this parlance
is six will be very weak okay here he
removes the night voluntarily may be up
for 96 ok I'm going to see three just
wait a moment I wonder if a five is
something
now probably not if it goes a five I
just go back 23 yeah that's good simple
I'm good he still has pretty good means
to defend the c6 porn it's not it's not
okay I was thinking this is good because
now I don't know how he defends the pond
if he has to move it ok this is now nice
here that the pawn structure now is
entirely static so going back for 93 and
then 95 those pawns on dark squares are
also where I want them on the bishops
bishops color complex yep that defends
thanks for the moment but only for the
moment Knight to e5 here
I go wait if I go nite c5 his rook has
no square yeah that's great that's great
actually forces him to trade and I like
to trade off this this bishop of course
so relatively dangerous attacking PS the
bishop so we're still Knight e5 is in
the mix and possibly tripling on the C
file and a5 is weak this is why I was
very am happy with setting up um we're
setting up this pawn structure here with
a 5 and so on this point is fixed them
so what now Quincy to probably rooks e7
I can take on d5 or a 5 so probably a
saguru k 6 no it just gives this pawn
way okay I think can take it one no
particular trick or anything yep let's
just let's just stop the pawn aged voice
also now upon that he has to worry about
okay Queen takes Knight g5 is easy and
this is also quite nice getting him into
the pin king age 694 it's nice
black resigns yeah it was a nice
strategic game this is a little little
interesting point them they all go here
that are the top players but he went
here interesting I took anyway which is
essentially the same position but the
but he does not have h 6 plate 26 is an
interesting tricky little move it goes
form maybe nitey form these ideas well
known from those Bishop before lines
this quick nitey form I just took it and
get to the same position now without
black having played age six so it cannot
cannot be really bad okay bishop here
I'm not sure about the rook placement
maybe rook FC one but okay yeah it was a
simple simple approach yeah but b5 is
quite um quite um quite shocking
actually there's no reason really to do
that if you I mean the night coming to
c5 is so is leaky okay and he can just
take it yeah if he really am it doesn't
see anything but I for exact let's say
he goes here for just for argument's
sake I do this takes gigs and he can go
back setting up this ideal night on d6
yeah that's a classic classic piece
there are only six many examples from
chassis astoria book bots off Petrosian
pianist portage Kasparov number of games
yeah he has no problem really but after
be five okay see poor now is is very
nice so I am yeah I think this is okay
but the comp wants to go E for to punish
black yeah for this yeah this is a the
computers of course technically a very
alert now this is totally out not
working so yeah hmm but dear may I five
etsy for strong he has to move the Queen
and then I get in this basically for
free now that's nice okay but I like
this if I was still good but a four is
keeping keeping pressure on yeah this is
a move that it's kind of keeping options
open 93 is still possible Queen a five
maybe he went a five and now I'm just
better after Queen d3 however the
computer points out that I can take and
go here and was even much even more
better yeah yeah that's very strong he
cannot cannot cover that I mean this is
the way to keep things I could have just
taken this rock why didn't I take the
rook I was so much so much liking and
those maneuvers that had even consider
to check through now I saw idea he gave
it away I mean I saw that I'm attacking
the rook and yes to take them this is a
very nice position now okay okay six
still defends it but it's it's quite
terrible yeah geez he's out of moves and
out of time almost yeah there was a nice
win though it's quite funny actin it
didn't take the Rope they are only six
okay well thanks for watching